buongiorno ben trovati a una nuova
puntata del blog mas oggi uno mattina un
po speciale un perché dopo i secoli in
realtà ho dormito con un'altra persona
ormai volto abita con i miei realtà mio
fratelli mio nonna anche perché non è
tipo attaccatissimo al cane ogni volta
mi fa ma che te lo vedi portare a casa a
mettere così tanta compagnia e quindi ad
esempio io non voglio questa cosa lo so
che alcuni di voi sono contrari allo
stare coi cani che fanno schifo ma lui
non è un cane una persona guardate solo
una persona si recherebbe le mani quanto
sei bello fanno dire a tutti come di
enti o un coniglio oggi mi sono
svegliato tardi e stanno arrivando credo
i ragazzi volevo passare una giornata
tranquilla oggi e quindi abbiamo pensato
di fare un giochetto fra di noi è un
gioco pazzesco in realtà non so se
esista un sensore c'è venuto in mente un
po di mesi fa era visto che la breve ma
temo che siano qui quindi per spiegherò
quando ci saranno anche loro ma tu sei
proprio un lord voldemort quindi volta
che vidi cani con uso non so mai cosa
farci del colpa tua
perché mi sembra una parte più inutile
guardati con il tuo naso e tu ti senti
sereno come dicevo la eccoli qui sono
arrivati i nostri meravigliosi eroi ti
piace neanche le abbiamo arredato il
salone si mamme femia fuoco al divano
forse più che altro le luci sul
termosifone
pensiamo rischio
aspetta contiene che pensierino per il
tuo compleanno
ma davvero era un po di tempo fa però
questo qui solo fisico ma perché è
abbastanza non è proprio dio è un
pensiero che il credito
pagine ronte immagina chissà cosa beh
anche perché non credo che in un costo
se si andava non lo so la fendi della
coppa da questo fatto non ci credo come
mi chiamavi il tuo e herbie cresce se io
ce l'ho avuto un periodo non sono mai
riuscite a farvi crescere in un cliente
ma veramente dovrebbe venire una roba
del genere viene così come non so se
riusciremo a ottenere questo ora posso
proporre una cosa ragazzi rimanente fino
a che nel video che avvieremo la terapia
e la terapia e herbie secondo abbiamo
attimo lo studiano in turchia si no
graviano oddio come che possiamo
chiamarlo se non quelle potrebbe essere
un nome che non si herbie fatecelo
sapere
herbert amici intervento norberto
chiamano d'elba ok vediamo se arrivano
dei dei suggerimenti migliori però il
gioco è molto semplice si chiama penna
matita e pennello è un gioco di disegno
abusato tu se è molto semplice ciò che
hanno in quattro in questo caso uno
riprende però di base
uno deve dare una cosa da disegnare
tenere il tempo e poi alla fine a fare
da giudice e ogni porta il suo generando
bisogna sorteggiare a chi capiterà la
matita per disegnare quella rosa
che può cancellare aki la penna
piuttosto maneggevole ma che non si può
cancellare anche a chi il pennello che è
diciamo abbastanza ottimistica ma questa
è una trazione ma possiamo usare anche
questo vogliamo usare quello quindi
usiamo questo pennello perfetto questo
qui via grazie a dami decide lui no
siccome o delicati colorati prendo dati
di colori completamente diversi il dado
è tratto il dado rosa ti farà di segnare
col pennello
il dato giallo matita il dato blu è
entrato del male no in rosa è a questo
ha determinato partito tengo io lanno
camera grazie prima le donne dai dai
il segreto ok
sarete voi già stiamo volevano aiuto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questa qui è una cosa che abbiamo creato
perché così chi disegna con la tempera
magari evita di fare un macello che
avete dare minuti due minuti
ragazzi siete pronti abbiamo per pensare
è quello che due minuti che quelli di no
ma il primo round
abbiamo la linea matita gianmarco penna
enrico pennello quello di disegnare e
babbo natale sirena via di renna c'è
poco ma non essere andando nei diversi
interessante quardati la linea anche
pazzesche amministrare e dicono no devi
fare un minuto come ma non mi fido cota
lega appare cassola al nostro nome
funziona
[Risate]
e nacque vedere che cosa è fatto non
vedo ce la faccia è un altro di gratta
come l'unica ce la faccia ma sembro io
alle pinne posto delle mani pure è un
misto tra pm e poi ho messo le mani
prima scuse non ho capito a un
preservativo alla coda peccato perché il
rosso come funziona il mercato matita
quando le alchimie votate non animali
non ha fatto in tempo però facile muffa
letti a questo punto pennello domanda se
ti avessero via domanda non avessi fatto
così finirà il pinguino di battute anche
veramente sei le macchie di rorschach è
capito che cosa ci vedi qui penna matita
pennello chi vince il primo round
fatecelo sapere nei commenti era il
momento di passare al terzo l'antifona
la notoria mazze con drive altri nefasta
il field of the least 321 abbia facciamo
tre minuti
no no col cavo facciamo un quarto d'ora
il tema è babbo natale versione sexy via
dai volti sembra che la meglio ce
l'abbia la mia il tempo è poco ma qui
poteva venire veramente un capolavoro
anche appello
e anche se molti ti aiuto io mi faccio
l'occhiolino il mio babbo natale si sa
le mutande lo slippino anno si stacca
manca giusto e bello capone matita
pensato di renderlo un po lascivo capito
che a questa pallina sci sparsi pallina
spalline lo definirà il più fashion il
tuo più che sexy il mio psicologo
sarebbe fiero di me questo è il mio
babbo natale con dentro rom ferdi se li
questo vedete questore gisin e pizzo si
capisce che pizzo ve li guarda a farsi
notare che alla fine durante la corsa
proprio l'ultimo ripensamento gli ho
fatto l'occhiolino ammiccante sono del
vince vince il pennello possono notato
prima il mio punto avere dato il mio
punto al pennello registrino mai
spiegata parecchie non hanno visto
comunque finita quel filone 3 2 1
vorrei che vi faceste un pupazzo di neve
versione mano e google timer due minuti
vai via praticamente faccio sempre le
stesse due tre manovre sono che poi
dalla intorta bene dopo la linea da già
segni della sua grande famiglia ragazzi
prima è che non sappiamo a quanto sta
andando ad essere davvero ragazzi io me
lo dovete fare è spiegare intemerata
parte di una lingua sono i miei calcoli
manca poco
così sono mettere partiamo da penna ho
pensato di interpretare il concetto
dell'umano diener e in maniera un
pochino più inquietante cioè come dicevi
tu giustamente poche le grazie google
cioè invece grano un ibrido fra la neve
è un umano ho cercato di creare un
ibrido tra un pupazzo di neve e un umano
umano di neve casual le scarpe questa è
neve ora non si capisca se la passano ed
è questo ciò che ho fatto io è la stessa
cosa di guglielmo con l'unica differenza
che il mio è più pupazzo di neve
bello il tuo sai che mi ricordo che
visto il cartone come si chiama il
gigante di causa non so che di di
glaciale astrobotic a quelle quelle cose
an che queste neve attivarmi sciorinare
il capolavoro potrebbe sembrare ad un
occhio muretto basso di tufano
macché del fiume la sua profonda umanità
dalle emozioni
non solo ma dalla totale mancanza per il
mondo che lo circonda infatti vedete
l'inquinamento questa sua profondissima
ma anche questa sì rispetto per la
natura da pazzo di mini c'è da dire una
sola cosa che che occupa torino ha visto
che vince sempre il pieno le persone
devono decidere questa grande tre roghi
della quarta mouse buy
fateci vedere lo sapevo che sarebbe
arrivato questo momento io so già che
nelle pareti quella cosa deve o no il
tema è molto semplice e molto natalizio
renna arzillo e che ho detto tyner due
minuti un uomo serissimi a pronuncio
creato di difficoltà
no ragazzi io dopo un giro del foglio
giammarco e saperi ma questa per me è
tanto difficile
niente ricadono
attaccata a sto punto con le unghie e
coi denti però perché ci si deve una
volta ci credo io non l'ho finito
questa è la mia prenda arzilla se bevuto
qualcosa sta bene se gardener aver
interpretato molto bene il tema perchè
ci si senta importante e ho voluto
tenerla appositamente in completa
l'opera non è un bravo è certo visita è
tutta in divenire andamento dio dai
proprio piccolo accenno di felicità per
rutor legali non gioco credo che dover
per forza pensare che un harem arzilla
debba bene sia un messaggio io credo che
noi preti cattivo criticare le opere
degli altri se no no no stavo parlando
di che sto parlando che comunque io sono
particolarmente sensibile agli animali
che bevono alcol e quindi dà fastidio
come versato quindi ho pensato che una
renna e argilla perché finalmente
arrivato il natale e ha pensato di reali
loro e soprattutto che il pensiero ma
bella
[Musica]
nel lavoro veramente grazie per aver
partecipato ma io vi spiego il mio
concept assolutamente contenuti sapevo
che non sarei riuscito a fare testa
corna come purtroppo ho sbagliato ho
fatto partire un corno dal muso farà il
verso giusto e sull occhio la verità
pace la bocca ma se la bocca ne fa le
corna
vuol dire che ha forse se impazzita del
tutto ma la vedo penna matita abbiamo
fatto se maradona che in questo video
lasciateci qua sotto i commenti in modo
da capire il secondo voi chi è il
vincitore poi finale perché non ho fatto
i calcoli il pennello vita normale
genova se giocherete a questo gioco vi
prego taggate c su instagram perché
fanno troppo ridere queste cose qui in
ci vediamo a questo punto domani si
chiama slanina molte nello non si tocca
non uscita e non è uscita la casa
cussina adesso prego si accomodi di
cialente sei tu che sei stato categorico
questo presentiamo un tema un tè non
però per un tema natalizio i re magi che
portano il dono a gesù bambino noto le
magiche portata di mano della serata
ma cosa
quando sempre no alla cava della capanna
è in realtà una tale cosa è la barricata
va bene giusto perché non a caso una
cosa è certa di una cosa il bambino e
nessuna abilità stato occupato se cambio
tua pelle laminata dal gip
guarda che bravura ma guarda che se
forte che fai infatti senza un genio
chase mercato to sigla ma cosa un
gingillo passo forse vero il mazzo
bubble 8 m 90 si vede che viene dalla
gloria di un tema che tutto sia chiaro
io ho avuto un po di problemi con il
bambolotto con gli occhi azzurri perché
il tratto improvvisamente era molto
spesso è molto nero anche c'è in realtà
e non è perfetto se la festa non seria
della fine ragazzi alla fine soggetti
dipinto con questo derby dobbiamo far
crescere un figlio così facciamo il
contrario
una volta a settimana ogni due settimane
non dobbiamo fare questa cosa dobbiamo
capire quale sarà il nome che lo
scriviamo su suggerimento della linea
pure vero gentiluomo dove stanno le
istruzioni l'ho buttata grazie dove
operare una bacinella d'acqua e
infilarci la testa dentro di te l'ho
detto all'inizio galleggerà allegra ma
più intero dovrebbe sprofondare dovevo
metterla per un contenitore
con acqua dentro aggiungi la qua sopra
la testa
ogni due tre giorni fa in modo che
rimanga sempre la 41 inizierà a crescere
dopo 57 giorni dopo 57 mesi lascia
crescere i capelli almeno fino a 5
centimetri di più e poi puoi iniziare a
darle lo stile che vuoi posso suo c'è
niente da fare
il signore o chiamare il signor qualcosa
perché è un signore si il signor
qualcosa possiamo chiudere adesso questo
video ci vediamo domani ma è sempre
un'altra puntata buy